[Musique]
mélanie pocket avec moi sur ce plateau
bon soir en salle pas de coup de coeur
culture ce soir ça c'est le mardi
vous venez nous parler de sport
électronique ou plutôt de heath porte
des compétitions des clubs
d'entraînement et des fans de jeux vidéo
peuvent pratiquer leur passion dans les
yvelines
alors avant de parler du département
quelques chiffres les sports c'est un
marché qui grandit d'année en année en
2018 il est estimé à plus de 900
millions de dollars c'est près de 300
millions de plus que l'année précédente
en france les joueurs réguliers seraient
environ 400 me et un millier d'entre eux
seraient professionnelle et du coup est
ce que les yvelines sont concernés et
oui pas plus tard que le week end à
dernier à versailles se tenait la
deuxième édition du tournoi heures stone
alors c'est un jeu de cartes à
collectionner en ligne un jeu gratuit
qui s'inspire de l'univers de warcraft
alors il ya autant de genres différents
qu'il y a de jeu et au mois de septembre
aubergenville un club d'entraînement
s'est lancé ils sont encadrés puisque il
ya des coachs qui viennent régulièrement
leur faire des séances d'entraînement
donc c'est à la charge de ses coaches de
leur donner des nouvelles techniques ou
en tout cas une nouvelle vision sur le
jeu pour justement s'améliorer et
s'aguerrir et participer aux plus belles
compétitions
c'est vrai que moi j'ai plutôt un
passionné de chifa dans ce club on joue
d'ailleurs à chiffa mais aussi à dragon
ball à quoi ressemble un entraînement et
en fait ils en ont de différents types
mais qui ressemble un entraînement de
sports traditionnels on va dire alors ça
dure trois heures deux fois une heure et
demie d entraînement technique et
sportif avec des conseils notamment de
maintien du corps dont il faut prendre
soin c'est le ses larmes pour jouer ce
soir-là il travaillait plutôt le mental
avec leur coach ils s'appellent alix du
lac c'est un ancien joueur professionnel
mais qui est toujours dans le circuit il
est aussi journaliste ispa leur
expliquer maintenant de quelle ambiance
dans le tournoi dé préparer beaucoup de
préparation mentale et ensuite en match
de vraiment corriger les erreurs pour
qu'ils puissent faire le le plus de
match presque parfait parce que jamais
le match parfait
or actuellement le plus jeune joueur
compétiteurs de la team à 11 ans le plus
âgé en a 27 et laure but de cette année
aller à la gamers assemblée qui se
déroule du 20 au 22 avril à poitiers à
faire assure merci mélanie pour cette
chronique